le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
depuis 14 ans à l'occasion de la journée
des droits de la femme
le conseil départemental de la réunio
attribue le prix célimène dans le cadre
d'un concours de créativité
destiné aux femmes artistes amateurs
relevant du domaine des arts visuels
l'objectif est de profiter de cette
journée pour permettre aux femmes de
s'exprimer et de parler d'elle
plutôt que de parler sur elle une soirée
de remise de prix dans le cadre de ce
concours a été organisé le 8 mars à la
villa du département
à cette occasion et pour inaugurer cette
soirée le conseil départemental a invité
une jeune artiste à se produire sur
scène mais y va fort aise chanteuse de
jazz
[Musique]
une voix suave sur des notes de piano à
25 ans maeva forez pratique un style peu
commun pour une jeune femme de son âge
le jazz au départ j'avais pas commencer
par le jazz c'était de la variété donc
du r'n'b aussi la pop
voilà comme tous les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui en 2012 c'est la rencontre
avec marc wolf devenu aujourd'hui son
manager qui va tout changer pour la
jeune femme ya marc webb qui m'a dit et
c'est le jazz
j'ai eu un coup de foudre des musiques
dans laquelle je me sentais bien et que
je découvrais totalement mais à
l'intérieur j'avais l'impression que
voilà j'étais quand même quelque part
imprégné de ça c'est une musique est
tellement riche et remplie d'émotion à
chaque fois et nous permet une certaine
liberté dans l'improvisation et même
dans la capacité à arranger les morceaux
de jazz et tout s'est vraiment cette
liberté là qui m'a beaucoup aussi
attirer dans le jazz le jazz est devenu
bien plus qu'une passion pour maeva il y
a un an elle a décidé de changer
complètement de vie c'était en essence
de droit et j'ai pris la décision très
importante pour moi d'arrêter le droit
pour faire de la musique donc j'ai dû
apprendre beaucoup de choses en très peu
de temps et mais j'ai ça me fait
beaucoup de bien finalement d'assumer ça
et de me consacrer entièrement à la
musique la jeune chanteuse autodidacte
voue une admiration à ella fitzgerald
l'icône américaine du jazz dont les
compositions lui ont permis de s'initier
dans le métier de commencer par de
l'interprétation j'ai repris des
morceaux d'ella fitzgerald qu'on a
réarrangé avec les musiciens etc
et puis là j'ai commencé à composer
parce que j'avais besoin d'extérioriser
ce que j'ai vécu par cette belle
expérience changement de vie donc un
moment donné je pense qu' il n'y a pas
d'autre moyen que d'écrire ses propres
morceaux et de composer soi-même pour
pouvoir exprimer ça je ne serai pas
moque même si
toujours gagnant avoir le choix et se
sentir libre de poursuivre ses rêves une
étape de sa propre vie franchi qu'elle
veut transmettre
j'aimerais passer vraiment un très gros
message c'est vraiment de faire ce qu'on
veut vraiment faire et d'être qui on
veut et ne pas être quelqu'un pour se
plier aux normes de la société voilà
c'est je trouve qu'il ya un moment donné
il faut il faut sortir de ça et ça
fumait soi même ab mais en 2017
le département a déjà soutenu maeva
fourez en l'aidant à concrétiser son
projet de concert en hommage à ella
fitzgerald cette année le conseil
départemental est revenu vers elle pour
l'inviter à se produire sur la scène de
la remise du prix célimène on
représentera ce programme dommages à une
à fitzgerald jour de la fête de la femme
m cette grande dame et un en avant
interprété aussi par mois kim jeune
artiste rennais j aimerais personnes en
excès pour moi c'est très significatif
très intense pour le 8 là on va refaire
le programme des là on peut commencer
par bhl au scan à l'espace culturel
leconte de lisle maeva et ses musiciens
doivent répéter mettre au point le
répertoire pour ce qui sera leur toute
première représentation de l'année
[Musique]
mais je n'ai de la femme quoi nous tu
venais symbolique c'est une journée
importante mais reconnaître le rôle de
la femme de la société réunionnaise
c'est le faire tous les jours et nous le
faisons à travers nos politiques
publiques reconnaître la place de la
femme c'est reconnaître capacité de
créativité le département le fait à
travers le prix célimène je voudrais
aussi dire à toutes les femmes de la
réunion
belle journée de la femme bonne fête
l'amour tout et merci pour ce que vous
faites dans notre société
8 mars 2018 à la villa du département
c'est l'heure des préparatifs pour la
soirée de remise du prix célimène maeva
et ses musiciens sont déjà là c'est un
honneur de représenter aussi la femme
musicienne la femme artiste aussi en
plus à mon âge c'est vraiment
un privilège je suis vraiment contente
de représenter le domaine musical pour
ce jour-là au département qui attache
une très grande importance aussi à cette
journée donc au sera là pour animer le
début de soirée avec henri rault miniac
au piano pierre et david boies la
batterie david félix la contrebasse et
moi-même au chant après quelques
vocalises et derniers arrangements le
public s'installe et à 18 heures c'est
avec grâce et volupté que maeva fourez
inaugure la soirée de remise du prix
célimène 2018 en l'honneur de toutes les
femmes artistes
[Musique]
sow
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]